This is the X-2. It was created to fly at Mach 3,
and to address the difficulties its predecessor,
the X-1, encountered. It featured swept
wings. Angled backwards to reduce the
effects of shock waves forming as the plane
transitioned from subsonic to supersonic speeds.
It pushed the United States understanding of
rocket engines. Helping to develop turbopumps
to throttle the rocket motor from 11
kilonewtons of thrust to 67. Something
the Bell X-1 couldn’t do. Its rocket motors
had one setting, on or off, no throttle.
The X-2 set both speed and altitude records.
But not without difficulty, shortly
becoming the first pilot to reach Mach 3,
Mel Apt began a banking turn,
while still above mach 3,
causing the plane to lose control violently.
He managed to eject the plane's escape capsule,
but was likely knocked out in the process and was
not able to deploy personal parachute in time.